this is obviously a very weird situation
you have this service that is run by
facebook
which has a business relationship with
the new york times we'll get into that
in a moment
then this journalist takes it upon
themselves
to make a essentially a dunking twitter
handle
now i'm sure the journalist is going to
say like oh i'm just sharing information
but this is an agenda-based twitter
handle
i don't think kevin ruse would have
created this
if it wasn't with the agenda of wanting
to show how right-leaning facebook is
so you have a left-leaning newspaper
that most people would say has gone
really far left and then you have this
agenda-based
creation of a twitter handle if i was at
the new york times i would have fired
kevin for taking
creating this news handle because it
feels like activism or i would have just
told him take it down
right and sanctioned him in some ways
like what are you crazy like you're
taking this data you're making this
adversarial twitter handle to kind of
make some
crazy point about facebook is right
leaning
that is inserting yourself into the news
story it is the number one rule of being
a journalist
is to not insert yourself into the story
and not only did he insert himself into
the story he didn't just tweet from his
account
here are the top you know news sources
on facebook
he made a dedicated service for it that
got really popular
now you have facebook having two
groups of people according to sources
and the sources are obviously going to
be anonymous in a lot of cases
that there are people inside
of facebook who are pro-transparency
including the former
ceo and co-founder brandon silverman of
this service
crowdtangle that was bought by
um facebook and then you have this sort
of anti-transparency group
which ruse calls team selective
disclosure
which included the vp of analytics and
marketing alex
schultz a long time facebook leader who
actually started on chamot's growth team
according to my notes here and the
selective
disclosure team went out even the
framing of that by kevin
is you know uh interesting i do think
that
it would be great if all this
information was public but
this isn't some big controversy here
facebook skews older
facebook skus middle america and
twitter and instagram are more coastal
elites and obviously all the
you know journalists are blue check
marked on twitter
so i'm sure the trending stories on
twitter are going to be a little bit
more to the left
on facebook a little bit more to the
right so much ado about nothing in a way
but it does speak to just how lost the
new york times is
in their ability to be objective and
just cover a story
this is why a lot of people feel the
journalists at the new york times
shouldn't be on twitter
because it creates this murky
relationship
what is going on here between facebook
and twitter and
why should the journalists at the new
york times
be essentially taunting facebook by
publishing this data day in and day out
to try to make some sort of point here
and brian boland who left the company
in november of 2020 gave the following
quotes one of the main reasons that i
left facebook is that the most senior
leadership in the company does not want
to invest in understanding the impact of
its core products
and it doesn't want to make the data
available to others to do the hard work
and hold them accountable it's a fair
point you know if you're facebook
and you give out all this information
and it turns out the service is right
leaning
and it's influencing elections etc it is
going to be
uh problematic and just like on twitter
it could be
problematic if it's super left-leaning
or you know when you remove
trump from either or both of those this
is
a very weird thing for kevin ruse to do
and rue said
about this uh every time a tweet went
viral i got grumpy calls from facebook
executives who were embarrassed by the
disparity
between what they thought facebook was a
clean well-lit
public square with civility intolerance
reign and the image they saw
reflected in the twitter lists in
september 2020 the economist published
an article
facebook offers a distorted view of
american news where the economist
plotted charts comparing facebook
engagement to website views
and as you can see facebook engagement
it trends towards breitbart
fox news and if you look at the way yeah
if you look at the website pages a
little more balanced
now you have to be careful when making
inferences here it could be
that breitbart bart and fox news are
covering topics
that cnn and msnbc are not covering so
if they were to cover stories about i'm
just going to pick an example here
hunter biden's artwork being sold for
hundreds of thousands of dollars or
whatever that story is
you might not actually see msnbc and cnn
covering those
therefore when breitbart and fox news do
cover them they get a hundred percent of
the attention from them
and let's face it breitbart and fox news
are going to write
even more sensationalistic headlines i
think than cnn and msnbc would we think
that that's correct certainly with
breitbart
i think they're pretty far out there so
a few company quotes from facebook
executives discussing the article an
email thread to the new york times
and this is a quote from the new york
times john pined facebook's vice
president of global communications
emailed the link to the
article this is the economist article i
was just discussing to a group of
executives with the subject line
the trouble with crowd tangle writing
the economist steps into the kevin ruse
bandwagon so here
i guess this thread this email thread is
not clear in the new york times story
was obtained by kevin roose
and that they are talking about him
framing a narrative
with this twitter handle this you know
antagonistic twitter handle
putting these top trending sources
which are obviously right leaning and
saying that now it's influencing and
spreading to
the economist nick clegg of facebook's
vice president of global affairs replied
our own tools are helping journals to
consolidate
the wrong narrative now it's not clear
the wrong narrative
the narrative that facebook doesn't want
out there or an inaccurate narrative
fiji semo the head of facebook's app at
the time
just tapped to lead instacart wrote i
really
worry that this could be one of the
worst narratives for us
okay when several executives wanted to
publish reach data instead of engagement
crowd tangles chief executive replied
that crowd tangle
team had already tested a feature to do
that
and found problems with it one issue was
that false and misleading news stories
also rose to the top of those lists
according to ruse's reporting
for the new york times so there's a
difference between engagement and how
many views people get to a story and
this is you know in defense of kevin
ruse and his
kind of metapoint or his agenda here um
and
and you know listen i don't think that a
journalist at the new york times should
be doing this kind of agenda-based
journalism maybe if it's on the
editorial page but the one point that is
correct here
is sure it's it leans right but also
that
fake news misleading news link baby
headlines they're going to move up and
there's two
types of traffic we're talking about
here there's the raw views how many
people saw something
which is reach data how many people did
it reach and then there's engagement now
engagement could be shares
likes hearts replies depending on which
platform you're on
so based on what i'm reading here the
crowd tangle
data is based on engagement but even if
you were
to use reach which i guess facebook
executives were hoping was a little more
balanced
it would still be problematic to them
because fake news
goes higher than real news
the new world of remote work is here to
stay
so are all of the hr and i.t headaches
that come with it
like how do you register your startup
with dozens of state tax agencies
or how do you comply with all those
different local labor laws
rippling which i use for my team at
inside can answer those questions
easily for you they make it easy to
manage both local and remote employees
and contractors whether they work
from hq or timbuktu when you hire in new
states
rippling can automatically register your
startup with
each state's tax agency and keep you
compliant with local labor laws
rippling lets you onboard new hires in
90 seconds
you can instantly set up payroll
benefits and apps like slack and github
and you can ship them a work laptop with
all the software and security they need
inside loves rippling because it takes a
lot of complexity off our plate
so we can focus on more important stuff
like sales and hiring in our key
business
and now thanks to rippling's new peo
option
your employees can likely access better
fortune 500 level benefits
for less than other platforms so here is
your call to action
if you're looking for an easier way to
run your startup remotely or
just a better way to manage your hr and
it visit
rippling.com twist that's
r-i-p-p-l-i-n-g
twist